as a student there are a few things that
set you apart from the crowd but one
that will take you Far and Beyond in
your life is the ability to pick up new
skills if you can speed learn where
others take hours if you can easily pick
up any skill and work your way to
becoming a semi expert you can go far
beyond the limits of most people so hi
I'm Charlotte Fraser a fair chair PhD
student in computational neuroscience
and for the new years I've kind of
planned to learn a few new skills that I
want to accomplish for my PhD as well as
for my personal life and I thought what
better way than to take you all along on
this journey and I think one skill that
I really have is to learn subjects quite
fast and I think this is not some
inherent skill that I have I think it's
just a technique that I have developed
over my life and I kind of want to teach
you this technique today such that you
may also become really good at learning
difficult technical topics and maybe you
think you don't have a math brain but I
want to tell you if you have a brain you
have a math brain it's more about
integration accumulation and training
that will allow you to get really good
at these topics so I will go over how I
learn difficult technical topics in this
three-step process that I call the
triangle of learning so in the one hand
there's accumulating then integrating
and the last is sharing so let's first
dive into accumulating so the first step
is accumulating the knowledge so let's
imagine that you have a difficult paper
or perhaps a textbook that you want to
dive into and you really want to learn
all the details and all the techniques
that are talked about in that specific
chapter of your textbook or that
specific paper so the first thing that I
would do is I would highlight all the
concepts that I don't know and every
word that is quite difficult for me to
understand and in general people usually
don't recommend highlighting but I think
highlighting is good to get a general
sense of the topics that you don't know
enough about yet then the second thing I
would do is after I've read this paper
and I've looked at all these topics I
would look up all these topics or on the
Internet or I would look in detail at
the explanation in the textbook then I
would write down what these topics mean
in my own words such that I could
explain it to myself in the future then
the next step is to close your eyes and
to kind of talk to yourself as if you're
explaining to yourself the entire paper
and this may sound a little bit insane
you can also do it Out Loud by the way
but if you're in a public environment
this is maybe not the most handy but I
would kind of just close my eyes and try
to explain to myself the concept and
something that I've noticed with
technical subjects is that a lot of
times you think you understand all the
details but if you actually try to
explain it to yourself step by step in
your own words you often will stumble
and you will often find that there are
little details that you are not
comfortable with and so then I would
review again and the details that I'm
not comfortable with and I would go
again to re-explaining it to myself then
the next step what I would do is or I
would find a friend that is lying around
or I would just imagine a friend and I
would actually teach it to someone else
so I would actually be speaking out loud
and I usually did this in my room
because of course you cannot just speak
loud in a library and I would actually
try to teach all the concepts that I've
just learned about to someone else
speaking out loud and I think this is
actually another barrier to learning
that by trying to reproduce what we've
learned in our words and speaking them
we will actually find that a lot of
concepts are still a little bit fuzzy
and something that I would also do with
technical subjects is that if you for
example have a figure in the paper that
is quite important I would try to redraw
this figure from memory and explain
every little detail in this figure and
by doing this this has a few benefits
you and become really good at explaining
actually and teaching things to others
but also something that I've noticed is
that you get a really deep understanding
of the material and of course I would
only do this for subjects that are
really important and that I want to get
a deep understanding of because this
process takes quite long but I've
noticed with difficult technical
subjects doing it step by step like this
really works and it also especially
allows you to pinpoint where in the
process of explaining the technical
subject you have some missing
information because a lot of times when
we feel we do not understand as
technical subjects it's not that we
don't understand the entire message but
it's usually a certain word or a certain
concept that we haven't clarified to
ourselves yet and then the last thing I
would do and this is more for the memory
part I would say the key formulas and
the key figures and I would put them in
one page for example in notion or one
page in a Word document and that would
kind of be my summary and something that
I've noticed is that actually just look
looking at that page with those figures
and those formulas I could explain the
entire paper or the chapter by heart and
not because I memorized it but because I
know the concepts in the paper I have I
was able to explain it to other people
and and this actually really allows you
to get a deep understanding of the
technical subjects as well as remember
them when you need to and actually
something that I've noticed is that the
way I learn technical subjects is
actually quite similar to the way I've
learned languages so with languages I
actually do the same so I make a list of
the words for example and then from day
one I try to speak with someone or try
to reproduce What I've learned and this
way I was also able to learn a lot of
languages quite quickly and that also
brings me to today's sponsor linguda so
with linguda I'm able to really fit in a
lot of language classes in my super busy
schedule and that really allowed me to
slowly increase my speaking abilities
also something that I personally really
like is that you can choose the topics
that you're interested it in and you can
practice as often as you want so for
example if you know you have a job
interview in that specific language in a
few weeks you can just practice for the
job interview so of course for the New
Years I'm also slowly trying to increase
my language abilities especially in
French this year and I hope you will
join me for this this year so linkuda
now also has an amazing language Sprint
for the new years if you take a class
for 60 days you get 100 cashback and I
personally think that this Sprint is
just what you need to stay motivated and
committed for your goal so click the
link below for more information or use
my code win which alota for 20 euros or
25 dollars of your Sprint registration
now let's get back to the video so the
Second Step that I think is really
important actually with technical
subjects is to integrate the knowledge
and what I mean by integrating the
knowledge is actually using the
knowledge on a daily basis so as
Wolfgang from Goods has said knowing is
not enough we must apply a willing is
not enough we must do and I really think
this is super important with technical
subjects actually but you cannot just
learn the information you actually have
to apply it to get a deeper
understanding of it and with technical
subjects I think they're usually two
main ways that you have to apply the
knowledge that's one making the
mathematical formulas or deriving the
mathematical formulas and the second is
to do coding for example and right now
I'm more in a coding phase of my life so
usually what I do is when I find a paper
or a textbook and I've read the entire
concept I would look up immediately if
there is accompanying code for the
textbook or a company in code for the
paper so a lot of times you can actually
find code accompanying a paper on GitHub
so also with this paper that I showed
you before
um the code is online and it's called
gradient analysis and when I was
learning a little bit about this paper
and about the concepts they use I also
decided to run the code on my own
computer to see if it worked the way I
wanted to and if I could reproduce some
of their results and I think this is
something that usually really separates
technical subjects from other subjects
is that you also need to apply it and
the only way you can really get better
at technical subjects and applying
technical subjects is just by doing it
every day so something I did when I was
learning mathematics for my Physics
degree was that every morning I would
just set aside two hours to only do math
derivations and that's because I found
math derivations needed a certain part
of focus in a certain part of your brain
so just doing this every day really will
allow you to increase your abilities in
these technical subjects and then the
last part of my three-step process is
sharing the knowledge and personally
this is something I actually learned
mostly during my PhD is that not only
having the knowledge and being able to
apply the knowledge but also sharing
this knowledge is actually a key
component of of the learning process so
something that Austin Cleon said is that
make stuff you love and talk about the
stuff you love and you'll attract the
people who love that kind of stuff it's
that simple and I really love this kind
of concept I think if you share the
knowledge that you accumulate you will
actually gather around you a community
of people that also like to have the
same knowledge as you and that would
also like to accumulate the same
knowledge as you so I think as soon as
you start on the quest to learning a
certain technical subject for example
machine learning or computational
Neuroscience it's actually really nice
to share the knowledge that you've
learned and this can be done in really
small little steps so for example you
could share a tweet every day of a
certain Paper you read or you can write
a small article on medium or write a
part of your code Solution on stack
Overflow and I think by sharing your
knowledge you will actually see that a
lot of people will come back to you with
more knowledge and at a certain point
you actually almost don't have to do
anything anymore to accumulate more
knowledge because people just kind of
give it to you which is really nice and
I think this is really the benefit of
building a community around certain
topics that you love so these were the
tips I have for studying technical
subjects if you have some amazing
techniques as well as to how you learned
technical subjects are also languages I
would be really interested in it so
please put it down in the comments below
and otherwise see you next week bye